let's make this gochujang salmon with  coconut pandan rice start by making the  rice rinse and then saute shallot garlic  and ginger just until shallots are soft  add to Rice along with pandan leaves  salt water and coconut milk mix and cook  in your rice cooker then remove pond on  leaves and ginger and fluff rice  next quick cure salmon with a one-to-one  mixture of kosher salt and sugar on all  sides of the filet set aside for 15  minutes add the ingredients you see on  the screen to make the gochujang glaze  rinse the fillet after 15 minutes  drizzle with oil lightly season with  salt then broil salmon for 4 minutes top  with sauce bro for another 4 minutes or  until cooked through enjoy with the  coconut pond on rice